Welcome!
We're glad that you joined us tonight
tonight we're our guests are Dr William
Johnson the editor of the Adventist review the
official organ of the Seventh-day Adventist
denomination and Dr Walter Martin uh who is
well known for many of his writings on the
Cults as well as the Contemporary religious
uh philosophy today in our country gentlemen
we're glad that you're here and I thought
that on the topic of Seventh-Day adventism
Dr Johnson the man that is sitting next to you
in your book that you put out in 57 questions
on doctrine that was the official statement of the
Seventh-day Adventist denomination to non-adventus
to the world in a sense uh there was a compliment
to the guy sitting next to you namely that you
appreciated the fact that when he with other
Scholars from uh other non-adventist churches
came to you and asked questions you appreciated
the fact that he came to you directly he came to
the denominations in in a denomination and did
research and Walter I'd like for you to kind of
go back as we start how did you get into going
to the denomination what was that process and
what happened while I was doing research on the
various Cults of the time and I written a book
The Rise of the Cults and I received a letter
from Leroy Froome uh top Seventh-day Adventist
scholar and historian uh the man who wrote the
prophetic Faith of Our Fathers and other books
and he took issue with me over the classification
of Seventh-Day adventism as a cult and I contacted
him back again and I said I was sorry he took
issue but that I had quite a bit of information
which indicated to me that they were and he
said well it wasn't accurate so I went to Dr
barnhouse Who was the editor of Eternity magazine
I worked for eternity at the time and I said this
is a very responsible man and I think we ought to
investigate this and Dr barnhouse said why don't
you go down to Washington and talk with them but I
know they're a cult because I grew up in Mountain
View California and I met with them all the time
out there and they were always giving me the mark
of the beast and everything else he said you're
wasting your time he said don't don't bother but
you I said you went down to Washington oh yeah I
went down there and I met with the Royal Anderson
who was the editor of the ministry magazine at
the time and uh the head of all Seventh Adventist
ministers and missionaries throughout the world
and um then I met with w e Reed who was a special
consultant to the general conference the Roy
Froome and uh TI unru who had gotten whole thing
started by discussing with us also in Pennsylvania
where we were headquartered uh some of the things
about adventism tell us about your conclusion
I came out with the conclusion in 1956 an
eternity magazine came out with a conclusion that
The Seventh-Day Adventists who acknowledge the
things that they're denomination were telling us
had to be regenerate Christians and evangelicals
and could not be classified as a cult uh however
there were Adventists that were on the other side
of the fence and we recognized them too we spent
the time down there going over their literature
uh which was a morass of contradictions uh and
materials that could be juxtaposed back and forth
either cultic or non-culty depending upon who
wrote it we had to go through that with a whole
group of Scholars And Men from their publishing
houses and theologians to sift through all the
materials and the result of it I propounded a
series of questions to them and the series was uh
later put into the book which you mentioned before
questions on Doctrine it was the first time that
a non-adventist scholar an expert on the Cults had
gone to the Adventist sat down with them discussed
their theology openly frankly and freely and I
believe to this day the men I dealt with on the
committee and Reuben figure and the theologians
who work with us were thoroughly honest men I I
was deafed in theology theological College when uh
Walter was dialoguing with our leaders and in fact
we studied president on Doctrine I was 57 with my
first year in school down in Avondale Australia
and we went through that book very carefully uh
it was applauded by the teachers there and uh
then later I became a teacher I taught for 20
years in the administ school system lastly in
the Seminary for five years where I was associate
Dean also and that book has been highly regarded
um in terms of the controversy John there was
some disagreement when it came out it um why
why why well remember I'm just telling you what
I've been told I wasn't around here in the states
one man in particular ml andreasen was not invited
to be part of a dialogue he took strong exception
to some of the things in there I think the two
that I've heard mentioned over and over have been
um the nature of Christ the human nature of Christ
and then some statements relative to the atonement
the use of that word atonement and um he he
became quite uh irate I would say and he sent out
literature opposing the book and uh some people
uh agreed with him he got a certain following
uh however by and large I don't think that was
a large following now that's my assessment in
terms of the denomination stand on the book we
have not recodiated questions on Doctrine the
book went through eight printings a hundred and
fifty thousand copies now that's a lot of copies
um it is still used in college classes um some
people feel it ought to be reprinted um we can
get into that there is another theological volume
a Seventh-Day Adventist biblical Theology and
process and we can discuss that I think that's a
major reason why we are not reprinting questions
on Doctrine but categorically I can tell you the
leadership of The Seventh-Day Adventist Church has
not repudiated questions on Doctrine okay well
let's Plunge in here Walter uh uh why don't you
maybe start us off with some of the questions
that you have already submitted to the uh the
denomination because you are saying that you've
heard some things and you are reassessing what you
were told the first time around as well as some
of the the uh the Contemporary events that are
happening right now where would you like to start
tonight I think that you have to begin with uh the
background we have already and also with the fact
that the Seventh-day Adventist denomination today
um to whom I addressed my questions responded
quite differently than the denomination in 1956.
how so um in 1956 um Reuben figuer who considered
questions on Doctrine and the dialogue he said to
be the most important single contribution of his
entire tenure as president Reuben figuer began in
his later life to deplore the fact that there
was a strong movement within seventh adventism
to undercut what they had worked so hard to
establish in questions on Doctrine and so I
after a number of ex-advinist ministers came
to me after I received literally hundreds and
hundreds of letters documents boxes full of
documents from all over the world Australia
and New Zealand England the United States you
name it they're stacked up that we had to go
through with people doing research on this
subject and they all were telling the same
story these ministers and these people all over
the world they were saying We Believe questions
on Doctrine we cited questions on Doctrine we
presented our views in the light of questions
on Doctrine and we were disfellowshipped we were
removed from the church uh I'm now painting houses
and I was a former teacher I was doing this now
I'm doing such and such what what went wrong so
I thought it'd be a good idea to ask the question
what went wrong so I addressed three questions to
Neil Wilson who is the president the president
of the General Conference okay Mr Wilson didn't
have time to discuss it with me so he referred
me to somebody else who didn't have apparently
the time to discuss it either and they referred me
to somebody else by the time I did get a response
the first question I asked three questions three
primary questions I asked them uh the question
that I thought was tremendously important which
is uh do you still hold the questions on doctor
and the answer was yes same as uh Mr Johnson
said uh I thought that's strange all these
people can't be wrong or something's wrong in the
communication system second question do regard the
teachings of Ellen G the interpretations of Ellen
G white of the Bible to be infallible that is the
infallible rule of interpreting scripture in your
denomination if for instance an issue comes up uh
where you're debating something and uh Mrs White
speaks on it is that the infallible voice is that
the end of the debate is that is that it that
question was conspicuously left unanswered and I
was referred to other materials which was rather
superficial and um I asked uh a third question
uh ask them about questions on Doctrine
and why the book went out of print
and since then I have formulated now a whole new
series of questions all right we're going to get
to those what I would like to ask Dr Johnson
is in my hand here I have just a portion of
the Seventh Day Adventist workers the former
Seventh-day Adventist workers ordained ministers
professors men and women that have been fired and
many of these folks have talked with me many have
talked with Dr Martin and uh the main thing that
I keep hearing is that in some way they touched
some of the doctrines of Ellen G white they
disagreed from a Biblical basis as far as they
were concerned and because of that they lost
their job I've done a rather careful study of
this myself remember I was in seminary I was
associate Dean I know these young fellas I've
been in Northern California where we have had a
number of young fellows leave the ministry I was
in Australia in August and September of this year
in Australia that figure is 60 6-0 total well I've
got a hundred that are actually documented right
here to start with and I'm sure I could get the
others for you I'd be glad to give you this list
here of a hundred is this from the United States
or does this include the figure film Australia uh
these look like these are all the United States
I'd be very interested to see it so on my count
the figure in the United States is around 60 to
70. and in Australia it is 60. this is an exact
figure in Australia well let's uh you need to
remember that in any year this is over a four
year period in any year in the ministry there
are young men and older men dropping out for for
various reasons uh now I I grant that the number
is much beyond what we would normally expect
we also have to remember that the worldwide
um employee account of the seventh the Adventist
Church is 60 000. I think I want to ask you is
that why are the the men whatever that number is
it's substantial the question is why is it that
these men that are basically feeling they're
they're holding with questions of Doctrine
preaching the gospel their conscience is held
to the Bible which seems to be part of the uh
part of the Creed that you're you're holding
there why is it that these men are being fired
well I don't see it just the way you do you
set it up there John I uh I grant you that
in some place it may have happened the way
you have described it but I've talked to a
number of these men and uh they are leaving the
ministry for various reasons frankly many had a
very strong attachment to Dr Desmond forward
he taught a whole generation of ministers in
Australia here in the United States he taught
for several years out in the west he's a
powerful preacher charismatic person a very fine
Christian man and his preaching has done much to
uh to revive this church The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church and some have felt sort
of a sense of loyalty and uh with forward falling
out of favor his uh particular interpretations of
Prophecy and so on not being accepted by the
church at large they've identified with him
because we had Des Ford here and when we had him
here um I tried to push him as far as I could
and he would not in any shape or form try to Dent
the denomination I mean he was Ford 100 right he
really talked a lot like Luther in the Reformation
he wasn't going to leave the Catholic church he
he felt like he's getting kicked out okay and in
essence he was trying to support it he just felt
that the view concerning the 1844 investigative
judgment was not biblical spent pains here on
the program as well as a Glacier View in other
places to make that known I've just listened
to the debate that he had and it seems like it's
very very biblical even if you disagree is that a
reason to kick him out well let's look at it
from another perspective we have a statement
of faith there are 27 articles in our statement
of faith here is a minister who feels he cannot
support our statement of faith in all articles uh
now the church members are paying his salary he's
being paid out of the tide that they they
uh putting in week by week month by month
you see here is a question of conscience on his
part there's a question of uneasiness on the part
of members the the church undertook a large-scale
study it went to huge expense in brought in
Scholars and representatives from around the world
more than 100 we met for a week at Glacier View
we we heard from theirs we studied his views
and the church officially in careful study did
not see light in his interpretations now here's
a man who was out of Step In significant points
with Adventist Doctrine and uh where would you
say brother Johnson um Des Ford's view of the
sanctuary 1844 the investigative judgment Etc
differs markedly from questions on Doctrine
oh I think there are certain important differences
where would you specify uh in terms of Prophecy
now there's as as I understand him um has
basically thrown out the historicist school
of interpretation it is fulfillment either in the
first century or right at the very end of time
but that's not sufficient ground for dysfunction
this is in terms of interpretation of Prophecy no
uh when it comes to um 1844 uh as I understand him
he would see that in terms of its significance for
something that happens here on Earth rather than
something that happens in Heaven above and that is
certainly a significant departure from questions
on Doctrine wasn't that part of the view all the
way back to Ellen G white that a person could
disagree with the 1844 investigative judgment and
that that was not grounds for disfellowshipping
wasn't this part of your literature
that was pretty specifically stated that um one
by Mrs White that you could have differences of
opinion and uh even about her role of authority
in the church and she was the uh one who exercised
the spirit of Prophecy allegedly you could
disagree with this and not understand this and not
be disfellowship from the church she said now how
is it that Ford who doesn't uh who has a very high
view of Mrs White and who wrote you're probably
one of your best books on the sanctuary yay
thick which you're still selling in some of your
bookstores for its own work on the subject and you
hailed him as an authority on the sanctuary and uh
on the investigative judgment and Ford comes along
and says well after some very careful study here
and in the light of course some of the things and
questions on Doctrine I just don't happen to agree
with this and I'd like you know to deal with this
issue and uh all of a sudden it's far beyond from
what I'm getting in the males Des Ford and a group
of men following Desmond Ford these are people
all over the place who are all having the same
experience and are all getting very frustrated
because every time they start asking questions
uh they they're not getting any answers on the
subject it's very confusing for instance let
me illustrate what I'm talking about um I am
met with a committee at Loma Linda University
a number of individuals are there of high rank
in the Adventist denomination not to name drop
but Robert Olson was there and Roy Anderson
was there and a few others and I was very
concerned about the specific issue about the
investigative judgment the sanctuary and so
forth and uh particularly Mrs White's role and I
asked the question at that time the same question
I asked the general conference is Mrs White
the infallible interpreter of Holy Scripture
and Robert Olson said she is the authoritative
voice I said infallible interpreter
that's the key I said because if Mrs White is the
infallible interpreter and you cannot disagree
with her on the investigative judgment on anything
else if that's true then she has become a pope
above the scriptures because who can now judge
Mrs White the moment anybody quotes scripture
to disagree with her the denomination says
you're controverting the spirit of Prophecy
and so I said what is the solution to the
Dilemma if she's the infallible interpreter
nobody can judge her if she's not the
infallible interpreter she's subject to
the scripture and all these men who are making
just criticisms exegesis and theories and so
forth about it are every bit as entitled
to what as Mrs White was I got no answer
at that meeting I got no answer from the
general conference I have no answer to date
she is not an infallible interpretive scripture
you're sure of that I'm sure of it yes that that
is your position or the denominations I think we
ought to go to the official statement of beliefs
and uh if you want to find out what Seventh-Day
Adventists believe I don't think it's fair to
go to this person or that person go to the stated
articles of belief how about the review on Herald
I'm the editor of that anyone hurt can I quote
you review on Harold June 30 1971. this is cool
the Bible is an infallible guide but it needs
to be infallibly interpreted to avoid confusion
and Division when will the people of God cease
trusting their own wisdom when will they come to
the place that they will cease to measure construe
and interpret by their own reason What God Says to
them through his appointed Channel when we come
to the place where we place no trust in manner in
the wisdom of man but unquestionably acceptable
of an act upon What God Says through this gift
then will the spirit of Prophecy have set
before us in the Bible and as witness in
the present manifestation this gift that's Ellen
White be confirmed Among Us and become in fact
the counselor guide and final court of appeal
among God's people close quote that's reviewing
Herald right now if she's the final court
of appeal among God's people if this present
manifestation of the gift of Prophecy is indeed
what this very editorial says then Mrs White is
the infallible interpreter of scripture by your
own publication if that's true Ford's right
this is one person's opinion okay the Adventist
review it is called the Adventist review
is not the official organ of the Seventh-day
Adventist Church it is the general Church paper
I am editor nobody is looking over my shoulder
and saying print this don't print this if they
don't like the work I do they find me but the
views in the ad Ministry view are the views of
the editor and writers I've been associated with
the paper since 1980. this I think goes back to
1971. I weren't responsible for that I was not
responsible I think it's very unfortunate yes but
again I think you should look at other things that
I myself have written in the a Ministry view where
I I State specifically that Ellen White's writings
are not to be raised to the level of scripture
they are not to be made a an addition to the Canon
I'd like to go back to the fundamental beliefs
of Seventh-Day Adventists supposing you raise
something to the level of scripture without making
it canonical supposing you say that something
is equal with the scriptures but not canonical
scripture I think we've been a real problem
there we got the problem because Robert Olson
says it is clear that this investigative judgment
is the correct interpretation of scripture because
Ellen White does endorse it close quote Spirit
of Prophecy is the only infallible interpreter
of Bible principle since it is Christ through
this agency giving the real meaning of his own
words Robert Olson my topic this afternoon is
on Ellen G white as an inspired interpreter
Arthur white Seventh-Day Adventists are uniquely
fortunate we are not left to find our way drawing
our conclusions in the writings of two thousand
years and more ago that have come down to us
through varied transcriptions and translations
with us it is almost a contemporary matter we
have a prophet in our midst yeah but what about
the Holy Spirit I mean do we have to depend upon
the spirit of Prophecy or is the holy spirit
antecedent to the spirit okay we've got uh
just about a minute left so uh I'd like to come to
the fundamental beliefs okay why don't you leave
us with that we'll come back to it next week
and and following this up but uh give us where
you're coming from all right could I read the
very first article I believe the Holy scripture
is Old and New Testaments are the written word
of God given by divine inspiration through holy
men of God who spoke and wrote as they were moved
by the holy spirit in this word God is committed
to mandia knowledge Essentials for salvation the
holy scriptures are the infallible revelation of
his will they are the standard of character the
test of experience the authoritative revealer of
doctrines and the trustworthy record of God's
acts in history and then later there is a
statement with regard to the gift of Prophecy and
you find this statement they also make clear that
the Bible is the standard by which all teaching
and experience must be tested and so I say John
regardless of what individuals may have said here
and there these are the fundamental beliefs and
we have no Pope only these beliefs that only the
church in general conference session can change
15 second comment Walter and then we've got to
be gone here supposing Mrs White says you are
to believe this and an Adventist Theologian says
this is incorrect exegesis it's contrary to the
Greek of the New Testament and here's where it's
wrong A B C D such yes that's four or Des Ford or
uh I can name some others grebel uh who have said
it uh and Mrs White was wrong she couldn't read
Greek she didn't know anything about the subject
and she taught something that was contrary to the
Greek text of the New Testament now if she's the
infallible interpreter and she says you believe
it are you going to accept what Mrs White says or
will you accept the Greek text of them all right
that's that's the question we've got the doctrine
on the board and we've got these questions we're
going to pursue this a little deeper next
week so please hang in there with us thank you
[Applause]
I'm glad that you joined us tonight and my
guests are Dr William Johnson editor of the
Adventist review which is the official organ
of the Seventh-day Adventist denomination and
Dr Walter Martin of the Christian
research Association in California
and gentlemen were talking about Seventh-day
Adventist beliefs last week we were talking
about some of the things that are happening
inside of the denomination and we were talking
about why it is that some of the folks that are
not Adventists are looking in and we are seeing
some professors and ministers that uh in many
sense agree with folks on the outside in Orthodox
Christian belief and these folks are being fired
and we're talking about one specific Doctrine
and uh Dr Johnson I'd like to come to you on this
you are quoting from the fundamental beliefs last
week and I'd like to go back to the fundamental
beliefs concerning the gift of Prophecy and the
authority of Helen G white and one of the things
that is a puzzle I think to me as well as to a
lot of folks is underneath the uh the paragraph
concerning the gift of Prophecy that you say is
the Lord's Messengers Ellen's Ellen White her
writings are a continuing and authoritative
source of Truth what does it mean for her
writings to be a continuing and authoritative
source of Truth which provide for the church
Comfort guidance instruction and correction
I think it means we should take them seriously oh
seriously well just as we would any any gift of
the spirit if we accept the doctrine of spiritual
gifts as set forth in First Corinthians 12 13.
um just as in some denominations they believe in
the gift of tongues and so on we should take note
of instruction that comes through that gift but uh
I would repeat that the bottom line is that these
the scriptures test every gift every spiritual
gift and this would uh include instruction that
comes from that gift yes but having to take
her writing seriously we feel that they have
instruction for us okay I've got a quote here
from uh from uh Neil Wilson there must be a
renewal of personal Bible study and family worship
a re-emphasis on biblical preaching and teaching
supported and strengthened by Enlightenment
that comes from the study of the inspired and
authoritative writings of Ellen White which is
necessary now what I want to know is if Ellen
White's writings come underneath the authority of
scripture why is he saying that it's necessary to
read that Bible in light of her writings is that
what he's saying it's necessary to read the Bible
in light of her writings Enlightenment that comes
from the study of the inspired and authoritative
writings not of all of the Christian counselors
but of specifically Ellen White which is necessary
well I wish you were here tonight to explain
just what he meant here that's that's our problem
that's our problem but again let's go back to the
official statements of the church you see and I
would appeal John also to to consider not merely
what the church has as its articles of Faith but
the way in which it is operated in particular
during the past four or five years effort has
wrestled with these doctrinal questions raised by
Dr Ford I'm a member of the Daniel and Revelation
committee which has been set up to specifically
investigate these questions we're a group of about
18 Scholars and uh I have with me at the the first
volume that to come out of that committee it's a
series of studies on the Book of Daniel there's
a second volume that the committee has uh just
bringing off the press there'll be three a volume
on Revelation one on Hebrews you'll not find one
reference to Ellen White in this volume not one
why because doctrines must be established on the
basis of scripture alone and so I say let's take a
look at the way the denomination is functioning as
does wrestling with these important questions
right here in our hometown a man that worked
with me on television that was a professor over
here at the college for two years he was trying to
convert me to Seventh-Day adventism and we talked
and along the way he came in one day and said
it's not biblical I didn't say anything he
worked there for about another year and then
because of the views that he had struggled with
and which he had presented in his own letters
to the denomination he lost his job because
his belief was not compatible at that point
is that's what's going to happen to other
people inside the denomination that do not
agree with Ellen White's interpretation on the
1844 investigative judgment it is not a matter
of Ellen White's interpretation what is it a
matter of it is a matter of the fundamental
beliefs of the church which are founded on
what on scripture remember that no doctrine
of The Seventh-Day Adventist Church was derived
to melon white no Doctrine this one included
she has spoken in these areas written widely in
these areas but to be fair to Ellen White you
ought to remember that she has written many other
statements about the Judgment let me just mention
one or two of them if Christ Is My Savior
My Sacrifice my atonement then I shall never
perish can you say Amen to that Believing on him I
have life forevermore this is the same Ellen White
all that all who believe the truth would
believe in Jesus as their own savior
and uh let me give you another one let me just
give you another one back from Ellen White all
who have truly repented of sin and by faith claim
the blood of Christ as their atoning sacrifice
have had pardon entered against their names in
the book of Heaven notice the tenses have had
pardon entered against their names in The Book Of
Heaven and as they have become partakers of the
righteousness of Christ and their characters are
found to be in harmony with the law of God their
sins will be blotted out and they themselves will
be accounted worthy of eternal life but if they
are not they their forgiveness is rescinded and
their names are blotted out of the book of life
and they lose their salvation John I can give
you more statements on the other side from her
but I think we really need to go back and and
look at at scripture itself yes remember Ellen
White amen Ellen White is not the answer or the
final Authority for a Seventh-Day Adventists and
certainly not for folk here all right let's
let's hear Dr Walter I haven't had you in on
this one for a while though what do you think
about this conversation I I couldn't agree more
back to scripture uh the point that I was making
before last week when we got to discussing this
very Point uh namely um Mrs White said quote the
Lord showed me in a vision more than one year ago
that brother Crozier had the true light on the
cleansing of the sanctuary Etc it was his will
the brothers C should write out the view which
he gave us in the Daystar extra February 7 1846.
uh the Lord showed me in vision that according to
any good Seventh-day Adventist means the spirit of
Prophecy is at work this is coming from the
Lord brother Crozier had the right view on
the sanctuary did he indeed brother crozier's
view was repudiated by questions on Doctrine
and Mrs white'sview on the subject was crozier's
View this is very significant because when we met
when you were as you remember before beginning
College I was meeting with Theodore happenstall
and Dr Murdock and the top theologians of the
denomination we were discussing this very issue
Dr George Cannon now professor of New Testament
Greek at Bethel Theological Seminary in Saint Paul
took his Greek New Testament now it says
fresh in my mind as if it happened yesterday
and he said brethren I should like to
set forth a question he said if you'll
open your Testaments happenstall and Murdoch
opened their Testaments to Hebrews chapter 9.
and Canon read and I followed with him that Jesus
Christ entered once into the holiest of all with
his own blood having obtained Eternal Redemption
for us and I asked the question and Canon did too
did this take place as Crozier said as Mrs
White said as the early Adventist taught
did it take place in 1844 or did it take
place at the Ascension of Jesus Christ
the Greek text says at the Ascension of Jesus
Christ once into the holiest of all the most holy
place just stop there let me finish let me finish
I read it I I was in the room when they did it
and when they got finished uh and the discussion
pursued from there the general conclusion was
that the text of Hebrews left no doubt
whatsoever that at the Ascension Jesus
Christ entered into the holiest of all with his
own blood having obtained that Redemption for us
1844 was not included in Hebrews chapter
9. It Was Written long before 1844.
Crozier said no Mrs White said no James White said
no the early Adventist said no they were wrong
the Greek text is right it's a question of whether
you're going to accept the text of the scripture
or the interpretation of Mrs White over that text
which brings me back to the basic question I was
discussing before is Mrs White The Interpreter
of scripture to the denomination answer on the
investigative judgment of the sanctuary she most
certainly is okay Bill I disagree this tell us
why I'll tell you why if my doctoral dissertation
from a good Southern University Vanderbilt in New
Testament studies done under Leander Keck who's
now Adina Yale is in the book of Hebrews exegesis
of chapter nine and ten I invite you to read it
I read it in the text that's good enough the text
the the Greek term is tahagia the NIV translates
this as most holy rfv translates as sanctuary
for my study of the Greek I think it should be
I think the RSV is correct the term is rather
Sanctuary it is the same term used in Hebrews 8
verses 1 and 2 where Christ is is set forth as
a minister a minister of the the genuine tahagiar
the sanctuary in Heaven above and uh sorry Walter
I I think the exegesis is wrong there no no I
would say wrong happens to all didn't think it was
wrong Canon didn't think it was wrong and Murdoch
had a PhD in Greek it happens to all had a THD and
they're every bit as well informed as you are and
excellent theologians and one was an instructor in
Greek and he disagreed with you he's your own
Theological Seminary he said no it means the
holiest of all that's what it means well I think
the definitive article was written by AP Salem
this has been quoted in the scholarly literature
over and over tahegiga it came out in 1967 and his
conclusion is that tahagia in the book of Hebrews
should be generally translated Sanctuary rather
than a specific apartment and would the person
who wrote the article admit to the Adventist
doctrine of 1844 and the second Department of a
sanctuary and Jesus going in there would they say
that would they say that Hebrews 9 would admit
that well I don't think you get all that from
Hebrews nine oh no not at all from Hebrews nine
but on the other hand Hebrews 9 is not necessarily
uh contradicting that Hebrews 9 is addressing
different questions it is looking back to Calvary
to the all-sufficient sacrifice accomplished by
Jesus on our behalf which makes full provision
for our last sins Hebrews is looking back to that
it is not addressing the specific questions of the
future the questions of the Judgment John on the
Judgment I want to just say this that if you think
everybody must have a problem with this matter of
judgment I think the problem is right there with
the Apostle Paul I don't think it's a problem Paul
who who so beautifully sets forth justification by
faith also sets forth judgment according to Works
Paul does now a lot of Christians emphasizing the
first have wanted to just get around the last part
that you cannot get around it Paul speaks about
Believers judgments judgment according to works
you find it right through the book of Romans I can
show you the things but not for their salvation
Paul says in Romans chapter 8 that we have passed
out of death into life having been justified
by faith if we're justified by faith literally
it says we shall not come to the Judgment that
ends in death we're going to repair before the
Judgment seat of Christ for the Deeds Done in the
body for the lives we've lived as Christians but
certainly not for Eternal destiny well I don't
believe that the judgment is for our Salvation
not at all the question is the justification
by faith is a gift is that gift retained by me
if I lose my relationship to The Giver that is
the question are you talking armenianism versus
Calvinism I don't even want to get into that I
just want to talk about the the important point
is that in 1955 56 when we were discussing this
with top Adventist Scholars the concession was
made at that point there was no doubt about it
from the book of Hebrews that Jesus obviously
entered into the holiest of all at the Ascension
there was no doubt whatever about that and that's
in questions on doctrine that it's true now we
are getting a completely different story these
brothers are being judged on the basis of their
assertion that it can't be and they're being
removed from the church because they challenge
it that is putting Mrs White over scripture she
is not over scripture she made mistakes she made
false statements Mrs White made a statement that I
think every Seventh-day Adventist or to know and
memorize Mrs White said that in a straight line
she had never uttered a heretical statement
she said that clearly I never entered utter
a heretical statement I will demonstrate to the
world that she denied the deity of Jesus Christ
which is at one point in her career heresy of
the Aryan variety which was espoused by Uriah
Smith and the early Adventists who influenced
Ellen White later she smartened up and she
said this is wrong and thoughtful Seventh-day
Adventist Scholars just expunged it the way
Arthur white goes through with his little pen
and removes sections from your documents and
ellipses I'm collecting right now a whole series
of Arthur's little pen and the things that you've
changed through the years it's scary to see
things Seventh-Day Adventists don't know are
going on things that are being taken out of Mrs
White Mrs White at one time denied the trinity
and the deity of Christ Mrs White at one time
was vigorous in affirming doctrines which she
later turned around 100 and repudiated when
she was writing that you shouldn't eat pork
and lobsters and crabs she was munching
on oysters and they were eyewitness
testimonies of that Mrs White was far from the
prophetic voice that is being manifested in
Adventist contemporary Adventist literature
I believe Ellen White was a Christian woman
I believe that Ellen White made some remarkable
contributions in literature I also believe she
plagiarized materials I also think as Newsweek
magazine indicates she borrowed from people
without stating it and if you're familiar with
the Foy Vision at all you know that she plagiarize
from Foy chapter and verse line upon line in fact
I have to hold on to that we'll get Dr Johnson
a chance to respond here let's take a break
and we'll be right back hang in there with us
foreign [Music] we're back and we're talking with
Dr William Johnson editor of the Adventist review
and Dr Walter Martin and Dr uh Johnson let me come
to you you've heard a lot of things that Walter
has said about LNG white please respond well I
want to respond first of all to the Judgment as
soon as I mentioned the the scriptural basis
he said let's not get into the calvinistic OR
Armenian view controversy there's nothing to
do with judgment well it really is because the
question is human will the place of Free Will in
what I'm trying to tell you is that the administ
the doctrine of the Judgment really Rifts on a a
clearly established tradition in in the Christian
church now if we believe that um really our
choice has no place in our Salvation that's
okay that's a particular stream if we believe
that our free choice has a particular role then
we go a different stream there's a large body of
Christendom over the centuries that has believed
that and the Adventist Doctrine the pre-advent
judgment is really solidly in that stream what
we are saying there is that the judge judgment
determines whether I have put my will on the
side of Christ whether I'm United to him it does
not mean that I have to somehow have come up to
absolute perfection in the Judgment not at all the
judgment is not to uh to tell God something that
he doesn't already know the Judgment reveals
reveals my relationship to Christ he is my
only hope of Salvation that is basically what
we're saying and you'll find these ideas also
in Ellen White but I uh I don't know why we keep
coming back to Ellen White as though she is the
Authority for Adventists here are our fundamental
beliefs and for uh ministers or anyone else who
has called into question they will be questioned
over against the statement of faith okay let me
stop you there right in terms of what you just
said are you saying what I'm afraid you're saying
and that is the fact that you can disagree with
Ellen G white on her interpretation of the 1844
investigative judgment and still be in your your
position the question will be whether My Views
hold up alongside these fundamental beliefs this
is the test yes okay now let me go back to your
buddy Dez Ford was in almost one of the same
positions he wrote for the denomination just
like you are I'm afraid you might disappear in
six months too you are you are touching what he
touched he sat in the same spot that you did on
my program and I said Dez you're going to be in
trouble and he says oh no no no I don't think
they'll ever do that and he would disappear
now you're saying the same thing to me and
the very same things that he was talking about
there and I want to believe you I'm all for you
Christians around the world are saying we hope
so I think Dr Martin is went on on a limb when he
wrote that uh uh Judgment of Seventh-day Adventist
back there in 57 he took a lot of heat what he's
finding out though is dear people like yourself
who are saying that and then disappear beside
behind and we want to know why what what's
what's behind us let me tell you what happened
in Northern California where we lost maybe 20
or 30 ministers I sat down and went over every
name and as I say I I know many of those the
students many of those ministers they are
my students in seminary the question was
can you support and preach the fundamental
beliefs of the church if this was the issue
granted brother that you may have questions
in certain areas you may be working out some
things for yourself can you in honesty support
these fundamentals that was the bottom line
and I know some of these fellows were given months
leave of ABS leaves of absence to work out their
their thinking some came to Washington to sit
down and and just talk to anyone they wanted
to some were told if you want to you can go into
the white estate open up any drawer you want to
all right but I've heard too this much go ahead
I'm sorry I have to disagree with that well it
happened yeah I was there I saw it happen
there are things in the white estate that
are not available to anybody but the trustees
and the people who are working at the white
estate are you just a moment ago you're holding
in your hand in fact what you urge us to accept
the doctrine of the denomination go to that
not to the individuals right all right this
is your Seventh-day Adventist encyclopedia revised
Edition review and Herald publishing Association
Washington DC published by your denomination okay
it doesn't go to your fundamental statement of
faith it says quote the best presentation
summary of SDA View of the investigative
judgment in current Adventist literature is the
chapter entitled the investigative judgment in the
book The Great controversy by Ellen G white from
which the following summary sentences were taken
the encyclopedia goes to Mrs White to Define
your Doctrine and yet you are saying that if
we go and start citing Mrs White then Mrs White
isn't really the one that we should go to doesn't
the encyclopedia know who we should go to you
publish it the encyclopedia is a publication of
the review and Herald publishing Association we
got a problem the problem is who speaks for you
the the fundamental beliefs are the
basic statement of the church but that's
not what this says this says if you want the
investigative judgment you go to Ellen White
that's what it says and I think the problem that
we're running up against and I ran up against this
in 1956 and in my research work up to that period
of time there is genuine confusion because within
Seventh-Day adventism there is a hardcore of
individuals who are determined to enforce the
idea that anything Mrs White said is the spirit of
Prophecy is the infallible interpretation of holy
writ they are going to live breathe eat sleep and
die with it and I've got enough quotations now to
fill a small volume on the subject of contemporary
Adventist leaders and Publications I don't care
what the statement of faith in your hand says if
the practice isn't there what good is it for me
to do to talk about Christianity if I don't live
Christian well I dispute you on the practice and I
think I know what's happening but I travel widely
should I visit the workers yeah I visit them too
worldwide and I I think we don't see eye to eye
on this right you have your sources of information
I think I have reliable sources of information
yes but your reliable sources are tempered by an
important consideration that consideration is that
the authority of the denomination dictates to you
what you can and cannot say it does not so dictate
to me scripture dictates to me Mrs White dictates
to you that's the problem remember I'm an editor
of the church I'm not an administrator I know
these people personally and they're prepared
to speak to me uh worldly and closely I know
they are and I dispute your interpretation I'm not
challenged I'm not challenging you in your honesty
as a Christian I'm saying that you are between
the Rock and the hard place because there's enough
statements authoritative statements to indicate
that strong leadership in the denomination firmly
intends to get rid of anybody as they have been
consistently doing anybody who takes any view
contrary to Ellen G white's all right let's let's
hold it right there and uh there's more we'll pick
this up from a different angle and we'll take a
look at some of the accusations that have been
brought in Time Magazine as well as into the uh
organ of the Seventh-day Adventist denomination
concerning the writings of Ellen G white what
has been found and what is this doing in term
finally to some of the administrators as well as
the professors so please join us next week [Music]
our topic tonight was uh was Ellen G white a true
Prophet did she plagiarize her writings there's a
turmoil that has uh developed in The Seventh-Day
Adventist denomination concerning the authority
as well as uh what it means for Ellen G white
to have the spirit of Prophecy and I think that
tonight I'd like you to go with me and gentlemen
I'd like you to look at the monitor here and we're
going back to a prior program where uh Walter Ray
a man that has done a lot of Investigation on the
writings of Ellen G white does Ford one of your
key theologians at one time said that he probably
knows more and has probably written more about LNG
white than any other living person and even in the
past they had an argument about the writings of
Ellen G white and I'd like you to listen to that
conversation and put them together and Ellen
Whitefield she was doing that I do not believe
Ellen White was a receptive or is an honest
Christian woman but we have had a superstitious
view about her as Adventists and Walter's right
we have engaged in a type of idolatry which has
been deleterious to Adventist Christian experience
is that she for example it's all right for someone
to copy the problem was not copying would be Mrs
White claimed to be inspired she claimed to be a
prophet and she also really denied her borrowing
now there let me read the ministry magazine saying
that did Mrs White make any attempt to conceal
from Adventists the answer is no she even
urged some as dad said to read I'd like to let
you see what kind of books you urged them to see
it wasn't the total one she copied from but notice
what they say on the next page on the other hand
she did not generally draw a particular attention
to her use of other authors I wish she had I wish
the church could produce one definitive statement
ever in the life of Ellen G white or James where
she admitted openly that she was using someone
else for that particular statement if she just
said now enter shine says or geeky says or Ferrar
says but you see she never did that so I think
this is the problem I do agree yes but now we're
beginning to put space between the health journal
and we're saying well it's possible that in her
health journals now because some of the statements
were ridiculous she wasn't speaking as a prophet
she was speaking as a an editor and Arthur white
is now saying this revolutionary of this santate
and Bob Olson is saying well perhaps we're going
to have to distinguish between when she was
speaking as a prophet and when she was speaking
as a compiler or an office amen let's keep going
yeah we're shifting from the superstitious view
of course so the thing that puzzles me there is
that we claim and he's read it from questions on
Doctrine we do not make Mrs White canonical but
in every case we go back to the Bible to prove
Mrs White I thought it was the other way around
we were to prove Mrs White for the Bible instead
if Mrs White says it and we say well the Bible
did that too you see what would you say is the
majority view of people concerning the Bible
and Mrs White the majority view as a pastor of
this church is unequivocally that Mrs White is the
authority and if there is a question on biblical
interpretation in our church it is settled
by the statements of Ellen G white not by the
interpretation of the Bible That's North America
not Europe that's why this is out that's why
Dr Johnson after you've seen and heard this
discussion let me ask you this in Practical
everyday matters we have been reading from the
doctrinal statements and week gone weeks gone past
the denomination is saying one thing in the
doctrine of beliefs is Walter Ray correct
that the people down below in Practical every day
nitty-gritty things the interpretation comes from
Ellen G white she's the authority when you get
right down to it I don't think he is John now my
perspective is a world perspective I grew up in
Australia I worked in India 15 years good night
in most of the world the church doesn't have the
Ellen White books only 15 of our membership is
in North America out of a church of about almost 5
million and uh it is true that for some Adventists
especially in North America they will go to Ellen
White as as the sort of the final Authority but
worldwide I don't think a statement is true I
don't think it is true across North America also I
could show you our Sabbath School quarterly as we
call it most Adventists go to Sabbath school and
um the typical Sabbath school lesson starts off
it has a day by day study it starts off with a
question the answer will be a text of scripture
there'll be more questions text of scripture
there may be comments there may be quotations
you may find a quotation to Milan white or you
may not and uh any Sabbath School quarterly
will reflect this all right let me let me let
me just throw this into you from your Sabbath
School quarterly uh page 92 April June 1976.
how Advantage the SDA church is to have a
modern inspired interpreter of both the Old
and New Testaments surely there is every logical
reason to give the inspired interpretations top
priority in arriving at our understanding of
the word today all right that is one statement
you ask the practice here I've got a quarterly
here and uh I invite you to look it over and uh
you'll just see the way I thought I had it I got
so many things here uh you've just seen away it
functions uh Jesus our mediator this is what
the church is studying and uh here we are uh
December Christ Our representative mediator and
judge but text of scripture statement comment
occasional quotations from Ellen White this
is the church at study we put the scripture
first Walter now brother you just a minute ago
started out quoting the Sabbath School quarterly
okay John quotes the Sabbath School quarterly to
you that says the direct opposite and establishes
Mrs White as the inspired interpreter and you
take the Sabbath School according to hold up
and and go right back to where you were before
what he said came out of that same Sabbath it
was one statement that's what you just gave us
is one statement too I'm just saying if you look
over the whole quarterly see the way you ask
me practice now I'm saying go by the week by
week practice of the church let me come back then
why is it that we find because you're saying that
that's not the case I'm saying why do you sneak in
these little statements from time to time then why
aren't they just banished why don't you say the
opposite that she's not the inspired interpreter
well I suppose you have individuals who remember
the lessons are written by individuals and their
staff is put on them and occasionally statements
get in that in fact they're not accurate in terms
of our stated that the leadership why is it that
you cannot agree in the in time in terms of that
which is taught to the denomination then because
the event of church is not a monolithic structure
we have no Pope and no Cardinals that you find a
spectrum and a wide variety of and diversity in
the church Walter you want to talk to that quote
the general conference one who's in session is the
highest constitutional Authority on Earth incision
that produces the fundamental beliefs which let
me finish let me finish when in session okay but
your theology your Authority for your Publications
everything that's done by the denomination is
done with the approval of the General Conference
of Seventh-Day Adventists you are copping out on
responsibility let me illustrate what I'm talking
about so there won't be any mistake about it quote
insofar as Ellen White's role in the church is
concerned whether pastoral or canonical I think
we must here give pause and rethink the acceptance
with ease of Desmond Ford's proposition for it
of course it suggested Mrs White as a pastoral
commentator not as an infallible interpreter he
goes on to say the scripture indicated however
that prophets have a gift of the Holy Spirit
Ellen White had that gift she was canonical
insofar as doctrinal interpretational Authority
is concerned close quote D.A Delafield Trustee
of the Ellen G white estate close quote now
here is a trustee of the Ellen White state
speaking authoritatively and saying Mrs
White's gift was canonical insofar as doctoral
interpretation is concerned and I have a statement
here which absolutely contradicts this quote
we do not regard the writings of Ellen G
white is in addition to the sacred Canon
of scripture of course not you don't need to you
have an infallible canonical interpreter a pope
who tells you exactly what the text says and the
moment you disagree with it like Desmond Ford or
anybody else you're out let me ask you a question
if tonight you or any Seventh-day Adventist said
Mrs White was wrong in her interpretation
of the investigative judgment the sanctuary
unclean Foods something of that nature she's
wrong and we disagree with her and here's
some scripture to back it up we don't take that
position what do you think would happen to you
the same as what happened I presume if if a
Baptist Minister stood up and said I don't believe
baptism is a significant Doctrine ah then you
are admitting that Mrs White is a test of faith
she's a test of faith if she's wrong you're out
no I'm not admitting that at all I'm saying that
because you just did that they're superiors
the superiors of that Minister would come and
say let's sit down and study this together
in between steps the final bottom line is
you disagree with Mrs White you're out no the
bottom line is the 27 fundamentals of belief
and we've talked about the general conferencing
session it is only the general conferencing
session which is a large Gathering from around the
world that can change in any way the fundamental
beliefs of this church well it sounds to me
Walter that that Dr Johnson is advocating a
new view and I'd like to push him a little on that
view and that is not advocating a news view okay
the view that I hear is that we can disagree
with Ellen White and that is of no consequence
that's what we're hearing well that's what I'm
hearing it happens in in practice in the in in
certain parts of the world that's the one
one illustration we're bringing up it seems
in practice that that's the only thing that we
can see against a guy like does four Walter Ray
Desmond Ford's teachings were tested against the
scripture and the Glacier View group testing of
against the scriptures did not see light in his
view it is out of that context not against Ellen
White because they judge Desmond Ford at the
Glacier View conference by Ellen White that's
exactly why he isn't there anymore whenever it
came at that conference to a point of disagreement
on what Desmond Ford was saying the appeal on the
part of the Adventist judging him was not to Holy
Scripture but to what Mrs White's interpretation
of scripture was now that's why Ford is not there
although I'm very interested to hear this because
I was there I didn't see you there no I was with
Desmond Ford for six months on a committee and I
understand that she was present and I took part
in writing the consensus statement for Glacier
View I think I know the Dynamics of Glacier View
and frankly I disagree with you as one who was
there well I talked to people who were there too
including Desmond he has a little different view
of you and he was the guy in the hot seat not you
he was the guy that paid for his convictions by
leaving the denomination not you let me just say
he is still a member of his church he has not been
disfellowshipped let's be quite clear on that as
Walter Ray has not been this Fellowship yeah I
know the term this Fellowship was used earlier
attention and took away security and took away his
reputation and discriminated against him publicly
and held him up to ridicule but we haven't
disfellowshipped him he did his painting was
not taken away excuse me he was going to sue you
wasn't he okay when we come back let's ask Bill
what has happened to the view of
Ellen G white in light of many of
the findings concerning her taking materials
from other writers that she said she did not
do we'll take a look at that we'll hear your
answer we come right back so please [Music]
we're back we're talking about Ellen G white uh
the prophetess if you want for the Seventh-day
Adventist denomination and we're our guests are
Dr William Johnson the editor of Adventist review
and Dr Walter Martin and Dr Johnson there have
been so many things that have been written about
the latest findings concerning Ellen G white
and her writings and right here I've got a
manuscript concerning the great controversy where
people have gone back and they have placed the
manuscript of the great controversy next to some
of the people that were around Ellen G white and
some of the books that were in her Library show
and uh it looks from this that many times she
took whole pages uh and just changed the words
around a little bit but it's the thought thought
by thought right straight through another man's
commentary and in fact what has been suggested
at the conclusion of this is that there is nothing
that LNG white actually had to get envisioned from
God that all of it was said before she ever wrote
a thing in somebody else's writing and they have
listed all of the writings of those men paragraphs
for paragraph right straight through her books
what has this done to the reputation of Ellen G
white what has this done toward the view of the
spirit of Prophecy that you hold concerning
Ellen G white today okay John first of all
let's say that it's become obvious over the
last few years especially as a result of
water race research that Ellen White borrowed
much more material than people had realized it
had been known for years that she did borrow
material especially in in great controversy
um sketches from the life of Paul this had been
known for years World arrays has shown that um uh
it's greater an extent in terms of the number of
books in fact it seems to range across the range
of right across the scope of our books and also
in the amount now in terms of the exact amount
um that really is up for grabs great controversy
is probably the book that would have the largest
percentage right there in the general conference
there is an ongoing study any parallel that is
brought to light by Walter Ray or by anyone
that comes to our attention it's underlined
in that book direct quotation or even a sort of a
paraphrase it's marked and um what can the people
in the denomination the little people down below
that are waiting for a word from the top here what
would you advise them concerning Ellen White
now in light of this let me just say on that
amount the amounts are ranging one percent two
percent three percent controversy is the highest
it's probably 19 in great controversy how has this
affected the little people let's be frank it is it
has shaken some little people see many of them had
a view of her writings as being coming directly
from God dictated by God and when they were faced
by obvious parallels some of them have said hey
you know this can't be this is this is has to be
a false driver when she herself claimed that well
she did make a number of claims you know that God
spoke through her and uh so this has shaken some
um and so the church has been trying to
help people uh understand uh the way her
writings came about I feel we have a duty
to to be open and honest with the church
let me ask you a real hard question how
would you if we were examining Mormonism
and you had uh Joseph Smith right at the time of
Ellen G white you had Mrs Eddie right at the time
of LNG white they too said they were speaking
for God how would you as a Biblical Christian
help us to judge when a person is a false prophet
well I I would have of course apply the tests of
scripture itself I would look first of all to
their relationship to Jesus do they set forth
the full Eternal deity of Jesus if they don't
then forget about the cleanse of those writings
Jesus is Central do they set forth the cross
as the as the consummation of the ages the only
means of our Salvation if they don't forget
about it regardless of their claims these are
the first things do they uplift the scripture
as the as the test of all other writings all
other writings how about Deuteronomy 18. uh
what is that one about when the prophet says
he's speaking for Jehovah and the things that he
speaks in the name of Jehovah do not come true
what does the scripture say do not listen because
the word that he has spoken is not from Jehovah
do not be afraid of him do not respect him anymore
yes well I think a parallel test would be the test
of Matthew 7 where Jesus talks about prophets
and false prophets and he says by their fruits
you will know them and what you said is sort of
an example of that what is the footage do the
predictions come to pass are the councils given
such as would lead people in the upward power
does the prophet in fact tend to exalt himself
or herself or exalt the Lord and um and you know
in the in this overall question about Ellen White
and her writings while you know this uh uh latest
research that has shown the greater extent of her
borrowing has been a problem and has shaken many
we also have to take that larger perspective and
I have let me deal with it as I have tried to okay
on two points first of all John my background
is New Testament scholarship all right I've
made intensive study of the scriptures and um I'm
not saying that her writings are on a par with
scripture but it is a fact that biblical writers
used sources in the gospels in particular Matthew
Mark Luke there is a heavy use of sources the most
likely um reconstruction is that Mark wrote first
and uh Matthew and Luke okay borrowed from mug
okay that is one thing now that's in terms of the
source thing in terms of the overall test and the
fruitage if she says something that doesn't come
true it's not wrong all right now I have to stand
back and say what has been the effect of This
Woman's Ministry and writings on the Seventh Day
Adventist Church but will we do that for Mormonism
because they would say the effect has been 5
million members just as much as I'm talking about
specific now you see the distinctives of adventism
have really come out of the council given by Ellen
White I'm not talking about doctrinal distinctives
now but about the way of life in the world um
the the health aspect that we you know we have a
chain of hospitals worldwide we promote a healthy
lifestyle Adventists live on the average seven
years uh longer than than the average California
um we have the largest the largest is a California
study I mean you know we have the largest uh yeah
see the largest products establishing houses and
I have to say while there are some problems in
our writings I'll admit them frankly something she
wrote I don't understand it okay I'm not going to
try and justify everything but I my my estimate is
that the overall footage of This Woman's Council
has been a blessing to the church and to the
world and so I think she meets the test okay
Walter you've got a book where you have constantly
have to deal with how do you judge a person is
this a prophet of God or is this a false prophet
how would you evaluate LNG white tough question
uh we get to the problem of Mrs White we are
dealing with the problem of uh in Matthew 7 since
you raised it the first part of the passage says
the false prophets can call Jesus Lord the false
prophets can prophesy and preach in Jesus name the
false prophets can work miracles in Jesus name and
Jesus said when I meet them they can even cast
out demons in his name when I meet them I will
say leave me I never knew you workers of iniquity
despite what they did in his name they abused his
name and misled people so false prophets can
look just like the real article you've got to
test them very carefully if it doesn't come to
pass according to what they say then you reject
it as contrary to the word of God now where
Mrs White is concerned uh Mrs White borrowed
extensively you've already admitted this she Drew
upon numerous sources now I'd like to ask you a
question it's not a trap it's just a question and
I really would like an answer because Bob Spangler
was asked the same question and I'm fascinated
by his answer and I'd be interested in yours
quote does unbelief suggest that what Mrs White
writes in her personal testimonies has been
learned from others we inquire what time has
she had to learn all these facts and who for
a moment can regard her as a Christian woman if
she gives her ear to gossip then writes it out
as a vision from God if Mrs White has gathered
the facts from a human mind in a single case
she has in thousands of cases and God
has not shown her these things but she
has written these in her personal
testimonies the case is a clear one
and that's a very clear-cut honest forthright
statement the author is Mrs White's husband
James White who says if she borrowed from just
one she borrowed from everybody else who can
trust her as a Christian woman if she says it came
from God and it came from other sources [Music]
oh [Music]
God
I'm glad that you joined us tonight and my
guests are Dr William Johnson editor of the
Adventist review which is the official organ of
the Seventh-day Adventist denomination and Dr
Walter Martin okay Walter you've got a book where
you have constantly have to deal with how do you
judge a person is this a prophet of God or is this
a false prophet how would you evaluate LNG white
tough question we get to the problem of Mrs White
we are dealing with the problem of in Matthew 7
since you raised it the first part of the passage
says the false prophets can call Jesus Lord
the false prophets can prophesy and preach in
Jesus name the false prophets can work miracles
in Jesus name and Jesus said when I meet them
they can even cast out demons in his name when
I meet them I will say leave me I never knew
you workers of iniquity despite what they did
in his name they abused his name and misled
people so false prophets can look just like
the real article you've got to test them very
carefully if it doesn't come to pass according
to what they say then you reject it as contrary to
the word of God now where Mrs White is concerned
uh Mrs White borrowed extensively you've already
admitted this but what's interesting is that Ron
Graybill who used to be effectively active
in the white estate I believe has listed a
number in your in the Adventist review April 2nd
1981 of Mrs wife's Mrs White's quotations uh one
coming from a clergyman a minister and president
of Amherst College where she quoted from him
without recognizing him she Drew upon numerous
sources now I'd like to ask you a question it's
not a trap it's just a question and I really
would like an answer because Bob Spangler was
asked the same question and I'm fascinated by his
answer and I'd be interested in yours quote does
unbelief suggest that what Mrs White writes in her
personal testimonies has been learned from others
we inquire what time has she had to learn all
these facts and who for a moment can regard her as
a Christian woman if she gives her ear to gossip
then writes it out as a vision from God if Mrs
White has gathered the facts from a human mind
in a single case she has in thousands of cases
and God has not shown her these things but she
has written these in her personal testimonies
and if they are not to be found in print and are
not brought out in sermons from the pulpit where
did Mrs White find them from what source has she
received the new and Rich thoughts which you found
in their writings and oral addresses she could
not have learned them from books from the fact
that they did not contain such thoughts certainly
she did not learn them from those ministers who
had not thought of them the case is a clear
one that's a very clear-cut honest forthright
statement the author is Mrs White's husband James
White who says if she borrowed from just one
she borrowed from everybody else who can trust
her as a Christian woman if she says it came
from God and it came from other sources you have
already admitted it came from other sources gray
Bell has proved it came from other sources Rey
has proved it came from other sources Everything
James White says necessary to disprove his
wife's Authority has now been demonstrated
and I'd be interested to see what evidence
you would accept personally as a Christian
that would tell you that Mrs White was a
false prophet what evidence would you accept
I think I've already made my
statement her relationship to Jesus
her relationship to the cross the relationship
to the scriptures no that's not the question the
question is okay what evidence would
you accept as proof listen carefully
what evidence would you accept as proof
that Mrs White did indeed deceive whether
consciously or unconsciously and was in fact
a false prophet what would prove it to you
foreign
tests have to be the tests but we can't
use scripture because she's the infallible
interpreter and if we use scripture the
Adventists will turn to us and say but
the spirit of Prophecy contradicts that how can we
use scripture you are saying she's the infallible
interpreter no you have said that I quoted
ten statements from your leaders that says it
I'm quoting the fundamental beliefs that deny
those which those fundamental beliefs today are
essentially worthless because you can find an
equal if not Superior number of quotations on
the same subject from your own publishing houses
which disagree with you Walter please I think I
know the Seventh-day Adventist Church I think I
know no no other statements have the authority of
the fundamental beliefs these are our statements
of Faith this is what we expect people to affirm
to before we accept them into the church could you
ask that question what would you accept as proof
I mean if if you were putting it in a courtroom
context and I said to you I would like diction
of scripture contradiction of scripture yes that
would prove it to you you know that Bob Strangler
the editor of the ministry said that nothing could
convince him so you have you're a step up from
him you say scripture will do it Hallelujah then
then let's look at scripture Mrs White says and I
quoted her before in her whole consistent chain of
Revelation Mrs White said it has been consistent
and that it has not contained any heresies she
said that Mrs White not only contained heresies
she contradicted the scripture she taught that
Jesus Christ was not the Eternal God in human
flesh which was expunged from your Publications
after she changed her mind but she taught it
that's false Doctrine is it not she said
in him Jesus his life original I know that
that's when she changed before that check your
commentary before they expunged it you'll find
it there Mrs White is quoted denying the deity
of Jesus Christ saying she is a false prophet
no I'm saying if we're going to go to scripture to
deny that Christ is eternal God would at that time
have classed her as a false prophet wouldn't it
I'd have to check up if it's there if it's there
if it's there I'd have to make her a false prophet
at that time at that point right that's all I'm
saying right yes okay that's all I'm saying that's
honest thank you let me also say this John this
is the final comment yes Ellen White wrote a vast
amount of material 25 million words probably okay
surely we're not going to say that every
word that she wrote has the same value
and uh she had letters she had Diaries and so
on and so the fact that you find a variety of
statements and you do find a variety of
statement has to be taken into account
okay and I think we do see a variation there let's
leave it with that and we'll bring up the question
that that raises then we need an infallible
interpreter for the infallible interpreter we'll
take a look at that we'll hear your answer
we come right back so please stick with us
foreign [Music]
all right we're back and we have a very
interesting discussion with Dr William
Johnson the editor of the Adventist review the
official magazine the organ of the Seventh-day
Adventist denomination and Dr Walter Martin
and we've got first of all a question from
a non-adventist and then a question from an
Adventist I think two very powerful questions
I'm just sitting there I've been listening to
the discussion and if we have the scriptures as
our sole basis for what we believe why
is it necessary to hold on so strongly
to a person what would this do to the entire
Adventist movement if they say thus saith the Lord
and just come to the conclusion the leaders
of the Adventist Church and say let's go back
to the scriptures and let's validate what we do
according to the scriptures and uh and not just
keep referring to Ellen White and going way back
in her teachings and I just like to hear an answer
to that where you go in terms of Doctrine we go
back to the scriptures we test All Things by the
word of God and hold fast that which is good as
first Thessalonians 5 tells us to do in terms of
Ellen White you have to consider her her total
role in terms of shaping the Adventist movement
I'm not talking about Doctrine the lifestyle that
I think this our educational system the council
there the health system our publishing system
our worldwide Vision Adventists I think are
unique as a denomination we are truly a people
with a World Vision and her writings have have
brought tremendous impetus in these particular
distinctives we're not about to renounce our
history and the role of Ellen White but you're
afraid of her you're afraid of it no so we are
not afraid of Ellen White if we fear there sir
and this is disturbing me tonight you know I I you
know I just uh I'd like to have this result my own
thinking before I leave here tonight I certainly
would I'm not afraid of Ellen White her writings
have brought me a hope and encouragement they over
and over say go back to the scriptures they they
point me to Jesus I save in my Lord okay what if
we were to say okay we can go with Ellen G white
as somebody like Calvin or Luther or somebody that
gave us counsel but the thing is not Spirit of
Prophecy somebody that took she didn't admit it
but she took from other sources there were some
good some bad she aired she was human she sinned
she had fights with her husband you know all of
these things she was human let's just not Elevate
her to that position could you do that well
what about a prophet in the First Corinthians 14
Saints are they human of course but if she doesn't
measure up to the test why not why why fight for
that I I'm not prepared to admit that she doesn't
measure up to the tests you see wow I think I
think she does in terms of the biblical tests
Walters I've studied them uh I would just like
to add from the kingdom of the Cults a perfect
parallel to our brother's discussion the Mormons
are larger than the Seventh-Day Adventists the
Mormons have more money than the Seventh Adventist
the Mormons have a missionary field of people
fought greater than The Seventh-Day Adventists
they have grown more rapidly they double every 10
years they're zealous they don't drink they don't
smoke they don't dance they have a health style
they work very hard at a worldwide Ministry I
have found them all over the world why shouldn't
I accept Joseph Smith because of the scriptures
because she contradicts them that's the whole
point I've been trying to make tonight question
you're an Adventist aren't you all right
let's have a question is it not true that uh
a scriptural or canonical Prophet as continuing
Authority a local prophet's Authority ceases at
the death of the prophet why is it that we claim
A continuing gift of Prophecy for Ellen White when
she died 70 years ago why do we claim continuing
Authority when our Prophet is indeed dead
what do you think Bill well Authority in
the sense of continuing counsel of values
of the church that is the the status of
the authority of Ellen White's writings
but you say it's more than canceled you say
it's inspired interpretation it's the spirit
of Prophecy the brother is saying the prophet's
dead if we don't consider her writing's canonical
scripture why are we still using them because all
the prophets that you mentioned in relationship
to Ellen G white that are that did not write
in the Old Testament they have no influence
on any of the passages of the Old Testament
the man is right they were just for that time
well I I would just go back again to our
statement of police the way it is set forth there
that we see continuing value councils in terms for
instance of our health institutions our schools
they were councils for her day but they set forth
principles that are still valid the health the
lifestyle that she sets forth continues to be
validated one more thing and why is it that we
just don't add another book and call it scripture
what is the difference between that and scripture
the difference is that scripture will test her
writings her writings will not test scripture this
is a circular reason he went through this before
how can you use her writings to test scripture
when it is her interpretations of scripture which
test how do you do it that's a circular reason
that's fallacious that's begging the question
it's illogical it's unreasonable it's irrational
and also the thing that I found in reading the
grebel papers was Ellen G white who said that she
should come underneath the scriptures when it came
to the people in her own day of judging her on the
1844 investigation investigative judgment at that
point when they touched it and said she was wrong
she did exactly what you say she shouldn't do
she pulled Rank and said it was because she was
the prophet she was the one that spoke via the
spirit of Prophecy and grebel documents the fact
that she did that so you have exactly what
Walter is saying documented in your own history
well again you see a variety of statements from
Ellen White and we must take the overall thrust
of her writings but James White says if she does
it once she's not a prophet of God follow up here
my other brief question relates to 1844 I wonder
if Dr Johnson can tell us what practical Christian
application is there for me as a Christian from
the 1844 message it brings us in disgrace and
misunderstanding with the Christian world and our
Evangelical Christians why don't we just drop the
thing what value is it as a minister I've never
been able to find a single item of Christian
value in that Doctrine yeah I'd like to follow
that up with a quote from your fundamentals too
concerning spiritual gifts when members employ
these spiritual gifts as faithful stewards of
God's very Grace here's the result the church
is protected from the destructive influence
of false Doctrine grows with a growth that is
from God and is built up in faith and love it
seems to me the 1844 investigative judgment is not
building up the Seventh-day Adventist denomination
well it depends on on the way it is set forth
if it is set forth in a perfectionistic mode
it surely will not build up but but if if it is
set forth in a scriptural mode and the scriptures
remember call us to judgment according to works
with Christ as our savior and as our mediator
and judge then there is much of value for us in
that the uh what do you want to follow up on that
I was just thinking of the fact that uh when you
say that it's not a perfectionistic mode the in
the very first program I read to you what Ellen
G white herself taught in the great conflict okay
if that's not perfectionism as a
doctrine that is stated I couldn't
I couldn't enunciate it any clearer than what she
did and I also read huge on other statements where
she said so long as I am joined to Christ he is
my savior my atonement and my security is in him
and I'd love to believe that but what do you tell
the people do you say that she was wrong when she
said the other statements because those are as
clear as a bell and you're promoting that book
around the world palmell right now remember
some of these other statements are also in
great controversy that where the emphasis is
on faith repentance forgiveness they are the
themes that come through in her presentation
of the Judgment could I just go back to to
the question that the the pastor raised about the
value of this Doctrine I think it has much to say
to to all Christians today all Christians the
doctrine of the judgment is one that is enshrined
in the ancient Creeds of Christendom it is it
runs throughout scripture Old Testament and New
Testament but nevertheless it is a document that
is largely faded out of Christian thought today
there is some important aspects to for Christians
to to be reminded of in this doctrine of the
Judgment the doctrine of the Judgment as
I see it is a doctrine that calls us to
to words good old-fashioned words that I
think are still meaningful words like loyalty
loyalty to my master the doctrine of the Judgment
tells me that Christ is my hope he is my salvation
his justification is my hope that because I am
his I must now live for him he is my Lord but your
sins are still with you according to Mrs White
and she said that I didn't she said in 1844 our
great high priest enters the holy of holies and
there appears in the presence of God to engage in
the last acts of his administrations on behalf of
man to perform the work of investigative judgment
so your sins have been forgiven you says Mrs
White but since 1844 they are remaining there
and they have not been plotted out and they're
not going to be blotted out until the conclusion
of the investigative judgment which means or let
me file that up Walter going to the dictionary or
the encyclopedia I'm sorry Seventh-day Adventist
encyclopedia on that very topic pointed back to
the great controversy where she said all who have
ever taken upon themselves the name of Christ must
pass is searching scrutiny both the living and
the dead are to be judged out of those things
which were written in the book sins that have not
been repented of and forsaken will not be pardoned
and blotted out of the books of record but will
stand witness against The Sinner in the day of God
our acts our words even our most secret motives
all have their weight in deciding our destiny
and also she said that the only way that uh
we have to overcome not only do we have to be
forgiven but then we have to show God that we have
overcome that which he has forgiven so if I do not
live perfect if I have not overcome any of my sins
and she says even my my thoughts of my mind and my
influence after I die my name can be blotted out
of the book of life but you haven't quoted the
complete passage and a great controversy which
is only fair all who have truly repented of sin
and by faith claim the blood of Christ as their
atoning sacrifice have had pardon entered against
their names in the books of heaven heaven and
they have become partakers of the righteousness
of Christ their characters are found to be in
harmony with the law of God their sins will be
blotted out will be future which means that right
now your sins haven't been blotted out when the
Bible says that the blood of Jesus Christ God's
son keeps on cleansing us from all sins first John
very clear so if your sins are still not
blotted out how do you explain one John
chapter two Romans 1 there's no condemnation
no judgment to those who are in Christ Jesus
I mean what are we going to do with that Mrs White
in Christ Jesus that is the it's a critical point
remember the parable of Jesus himself but are you
in Christ I am in Christ are your sins blotted out
Jesus is taking care of myself they blotted out
come on my sins are forgiven you're honest come
on my sins are forgiving let me finish my Parable
okay the parents rest of Matthew chapter 18. let's
go back to the words of the master remember
the parable of the two debtors how this uh
this man takes account and uh as Stewart has
brought in this fellow has a fantastic debt 10
000 talents in terms of um money today it's almost
Beyond uh computation it's millions and millions
an incredible sum this man comes in and asks for
a little time give me time I don't know how much
time he wanted to pay it off but uh the the master
says it's all right you're forgiven the dead is
canceled okay the dead is canceled but the parable
doesn't end there because his same servant goes
away and he he gets a fellow servant who owes
him a hundred Pence and grabs him by the neck
and says you pay me the last penny or else you go
into jail and you stay there till you pay it and
Jesus says at the end of the parable throw that
Wicked servant who has forgiven so much throw him
into out of Darkness you see John the development
of his responsibility the intent of the parable
of this the two things going on here well as I
understand it number one God's incredible Grace
incredible Grace that pays my debt I could live
a million years I could never atone for my sins
only Jesus can do it it's all paid for it it's
all paid for the second part of the parable is
this by the blood of Jesus right the second part
of the parable is this that having been forgiven
because I am his my life will now reflect his life
as he is merciful I in my imperfect sphere will
reflect his life will not be canceled finally
until he ended the investigative judgment and
until then you're going to sweat it but if if my
life does not reflect that then his forgiveness
counts for nothing you have to reflect it what's
that to what degree do you have to reflect
obedience obedience to the law of God particularly
the Sabbath not a perfect obedience she said it
was perfect Every Act every word every deed every
every motive including your influence after you
die these are the things you see that confuse
evangelicals raised on Reformation theology
because we believe in salvation by grace only
justification by faith Adventist Doctrine States
they believe it also but what happens is you're
saved by grace and kept by works and until the
end of the investigative judgment if you don't
toe the line on the works you lose your salvation
rather Martin I refer you to Paul Paul calls us to
judgment according to our works and every one of
us is going to give account before God according
to our word but not for our souls we are not going
to be saved by our works right but the works
will show whether we are in relationship to
Jesus Christ whether we are his or not our works
will testify to the existence of saving Faith are
you going to accept what Mrs White says or you
accept the Greek text of them all right that's
that's the question we've got the doctrine
on the board and we've got these questions
we're going to pursue this a little deeper next
week so please hang in there with us [Music]
welcome
what an enthusiastic crowd we've got here in
the studio I'll tell you what we're glad that
they're here we're glad that you've joined
us tonight we're talking about Seventh-Day
adventism and my guests are Dr William Johnson
the editor of the Adventist review the official
organ uh magazine of The Seventh-Day Adventist
denomination as well as Dr Walter Martin and
gentlemen I'm coming to you to this week to ask
a question namely in 57 when the denomination
came out with the book questions on Doctrine
replying to many of the questions of Walter
Martin Harold linzel and other evangelicals
outside of adventism asked the denomination
when they were answered if some of those things
have changed now what would have to change for
Walter Martin to take the heat the other way
he took the heat in the sense that he said
Seventh-Day adventism was not a cult there was
enough Christian doctrine there on the main points
that they were not occult what would have
to change Walter for you to call them a cult
and we might go on to the next step do
you think it's heading that direction
I think that from the material we're now seeing
come out from the changes which are taking place
in terms of the uh ministers workers and people
I dispute uh brother Johnson's claim of just a
few uh I'm familiar with over 200 now and I think
I can go back and dig up an awful lot more from
our files that were forcibly ejected from the
denomination uh for holding questions on Doctrine
and quoting it at their uh when they were brought
up to discuss it uh I think that they are moving
because of their view of Mrs White which is not
changing or not changed or never changed I should
have to think about that because I believe the men
I dealt with were honest men but I think what's
happening is that there are people as I've quoted
while I've been on the show numerous sources uh
where men have specifically stated that she is the
interpretive Authority and uh you involve yourself
in circular reasoning because if the Bible is
supposed to be the judge of everything and there
is someone who judges the Bible or interprets the
Bible for you that's the final court of appeal
for you to quote Mr Delafield of the Ellen White
estate and others then you're in a circle there's
no way to ascertain truth there's no way to break
out of that Circle and I think if they persist in
that direction the great fear that I have is that
the evangelicals and even some fundamentalists
who in the early 1950s considered the Adventists
a non-Christian cult and wrote them off in effect
as far as Fellowship goes or anything else is
concerned and had a lot of bad blood as a result
of it that they will begin to reevaluate and
say uh you know this stuff that we're seeing now
indicates that there never really was any change
and that they have not told you the truth and they
didn't tell barnhouse the truth and uh that uh you
misled and you've got to set the record straight
now what I think the Adventists failed to
recognize is that since using their own statistics
since the year 1955 when they reached their
first million they have grown from 55 to 84.
3 million more than that they could never have
achieved this without the fellowship Open Door
open hand and cooperation of large segments of
the Evangelical world and I have been told that
by top Adventists who thank God that questions on
Doctrine was published and that there was an open
hand to Adventist at that time as many of them
Brothers and Sisters in Christ and I fear that
what's going to happen is that the work of Godly
men such as Ellie Froome are our figure uh tobiano
w e Reid and Roy Allen Anderson and all
the effort done by Adventist leaders
who love the Lord and worked very hard to see
that this was a representative view of their
denomination is not being jeopardized by a group
of people who apparently are very high placed with
great power and authority and do influence their
denominations so much so that there is no way to
control the publishing houses in terms of what
they print we've been sitting here with uh our
brother and we have seen him quote a publication
and the quota publication and they both came
from Seventh-day Adventist publishing houses
we have seen that there are people out there
talking and high levels of adventism even in the
Sabbath quarterly things which themselves are the
antithesis of questions on Doctrine I fear that
if they continue to progress at this rate that
the classification of a cult can't possibly miss
being reapplied to Seventh-Day adventism because
once you have an interpreter of scripture a final
court of appeal that tells you what scripture
means as soon as you judge scripture by that as
soon as you have someone who has made doctrinal
errors in the past even on the deity of Christ and
the the doctrine of the atonement and other things
and that person is raised to that position or
authority you have polarization around that person
and I could give you 20 quotations right now
from high Adventist sources and Publications
all stating these tremendously overblown views of
Ellen White views I might add that she herself in
certain sections repudiated okay let's come to to
bill because Bill I feel that that you don't want
that to happen and as I hear you in a sense as
I've already said in some of the other programs
for some of the views that you have said because
of uh well let's let's name it your view in terms
of the 1844 investigative judgment from what I
see of LNG white from the encyclopedia and from
the book great controversy differs with what she
stated there you're saying that you as the editor
of the the organ of the denomination you can
say that you have no fear I I fear for you let
me come from this perspective if you're listening
to Walter and he's starting to get scared and I'm
starting to get scared how can you what do you
think folks inside of adventism can do should do
to alleviate to disperse these fears John first of
all I have to say that I don't read the situation
just the same as you do and the same as Walter
does I'm not afraid and furthermore I'd rather
be true to my own conscience that's more
important than any job to me it's true but
um you have to take into account that the uh
My Views have been on record for years I've
written six books probably 300 articles and
they knew what they were getting when they
asked me to be editor of the church paper now
that surely said something so it's not as if
I have changed my views for tonight's audience
and My Views are held quite widely I love you
that's why I really enjoy your fellowship but
what I have to say is that two years ago I sat
with a guy that was also from Australia who
is also one of the top denominational writers
he wrote for the denomination he wrote some of
your main articles and he said the same thing
and he's no longer a part of the teaching crowd
what he would say about 1844 in the judgment is
not the same as I would say but yours is both
both of you are different than Ellen G white
again I would say look at the total context of
Ellen White's statements about the Judgment I
read one I could read many more over and over
she comes back to the words repentance Faith
Jesus is our only hope in the Judgment now there
are some statements where she holds up the uh the
sort of the goal of sanctification of growing
more and more like Jesus some of those who've
just read alone can come across in a sort of a
perfectionistic mode but you have to look at the
total scope I don't think I'm out of harmony
with the overall thrust but you see a variety
that's true I'm hoping that that you are the true
representative of the leadership at the top and
what I'm saying is when you have a fellow like
Dr Martin that has already stuck his neck out
when some of the other evangelicals went the other
direction he says we need to continue Fellowship
these folks are Christian Brothers I hear him
saying he wants to continue doing that but he
is not having some of these things answered and
secondly when he has gone to the top he has not
gotten the courtesy that he did in 57. let me
just say a word about our relationship to the
Evangelical John okay I think we fit there
better than anywhere else you know if you
take George Gallup Junior's um characteristics
of evangelicals Born Again centrality of Jesus
authority of the word and witnessing evangelism
all those apply Right Down the Line I think we
fit among the evangelicals but we also have our
own distinctives and frankly I am not uh really
interested in taking a position that would say
all right in order to be defeat absolutely with
the evangelicals forget about the distinctives I
think the distinctives of adventism have something
to say to the world and I think something to say
to other evangelicals I think evangelicals will
be the loser also if you consider that we're no
longer part of the pale but if we're all part of
the same families I read scripture here and let's
just quote scripture at this point if you and I
are brothers and you and I have disagreements
on other things that we would say are not the
essentials although it gets real close to them on
those things we've got to have some dialogue we've
got to have some discussion and we've got to make
the Bible Central and at that point it seems that
when we bring up some of these discussions and
we put it down on the biblical floor the people
inside of adventism that have been doing that
with us that we have appreciated their Fellowship
those people on a practical level disappear
we saw we also should take into consideration
another thing I think is neglected if Adventists
are recognized as members of the body of Christ
then as they explained it in questions on
Doctrine their Remnant Church idea is not
to make them independent of the body of Christ
but it's something that they understand uniquely
for themselves in questions I'm Doctrine they
said Mrs White spoke authoritatively to the
Adventist Church it was for them inspired counsel
from the Lord but first Corinthians chapter 14
since Bill quoted First Corinthians 12 before
First Corinthians chapter 14 follows that and
it says that the prophet who exercises a spiritual
gift is to be tested and when you how do you test
that profit you have to test that profit by the
authority of the word of God and when you find
that Mrs White is inconsistent with the word of
God when you prove it from the Greek and from
the Hebrew when you give good solid exegetical
arguments and in love as a lifelong member of a
denomination you take a stand saying this is wrong
this is what scripture says then the spirit of
Prophecy is invoked against you and you're down
the tubes that's what I'm protesting against if
we're members of the body of Christ then we
have to come have concern for each other we
have to love each other and care for each other I
don't find the current leadership of the Adventist
denomination caring for or having love for the
people that it summarily dismissed I find some of
their best people disappearing for doing nothing
more than quoting questions on Doctrine I really
could care less about the opinion of the editor of
the review and Herald that's one man's opinion by
his own statement I want to know all about these
hundreds of people who come up with the same
material and the same arguments and the same facts
and quote questions on Doctrine and they're gone
I want to know is that showing them love
is that showing compassion I don't think
so okay we're gonna take a break then we've got
a lot of people in our audience here that uh uh
have lots of questions and we'll get to that as
soon as we come right back stick with us [Music]
Bill are we in the same spot that we were at in
57 before questions on a doctor no we are not in
the same spot okay I I have to tell you I think
you two men read the church differently from the
way I read it but I guess what I'm saying is
I hear you're saying that and I need help and
I guess Walter needs help how can you help us yes
we we'd like to know where we're reading it wrong
I would say go to our our statement of
beliefs look at the way we are working
as we are wrestling with doctrinal problems
the Publications that are coming out of of
the top level Committees of the church okay
Bill let me come back to you in all love and
simply say that I've done that and I hear Walter
saying that and then I pick out some of the top
leadership we're not taking people that are
nobodies we're taking the leadership of the
church up there LNG white estate some of the
people that are presidents of the conferences
I mean right straight across the board and these
people are making the statements that we object to
thank you I think Walter told you that um the
reply to his letter by the way came from a vice
president of the General Conference it wasn't a
nobody Dr Leisure who is the uh was the director
of the biblical Research Institute he wasn't
a nobody and he said straight out we have not
repudiated questions on Doctrine he did not answer
my question quote do you believe that Ellen White
is the infallible interpreter of Holy scripture
for The Seventh-Day Adventist denomination
draw the blank refer to the sheet of paper
that you had in your hand but no answer
why the question wasn't answered well he drew
attention to a a statement about the relationship
of Ellen White's um authority to the scriptures
and uh I guess he simply said uh brother Walter
here is a statement that we produced when I just
say brother Walter no brother Walter yes brother
Walter yes or no here's the reason why or why not
I can read through the statement or parts of it
we do not believe that the writings of Ellen White
are in addition to the Canon of Satan scripture we
do not believe that the writings of Ellen White
function as the foundation and final authority
of Christian faith has that scripture we do not
believe that the writings of Ellen White may be
used as the basis of Doctrine we do not believe
that the study of the writings of Ellen White
may be used to replace the study of scripture we
do not believe that scripture can be understood
only through the writings of Ellen White we do
not believe that Ellen White is the infallible
interpreter of scripture for the Seventh Adventist
why isn't that there because in fact she is and if
you cross her you are not there I guarantee you as
editor of the review if you start writing articles
using scripture to call into question specific
teachings of Mrs White you won't be there either
and we don't want to see that bill we would like
to hear what you're saying and I guess we're
saying that we respect you for saying we love
you for showing up tonight to say this because
uh last time when we had Dez here and when we had
Walter and Time Magazine was coming out that very
night that we did the program with an article
right across the nation we asked Neil Wilson and
14 other people to come and to to say something
so that you have come I love you for doing that
and I fear for what you're saying because you
are saying that we are not rightly judging the
church right absolutely but on the other hand if
we are then you're in Jeopardy right now John a
major reason that I came tonight was that I felt
the church was not fairly represented in its in
the previous telecast now you are so gracious as
to invite me a couple of years ago I was away on
vacation that week I couldn't make it but this
time I was able to come and I'm glad to I'm glad
that you are you are representing an important
perspective on the church and Walter is reminding
us of a real danger and I appreciate that just
as I appreciate very much the work you did for us
back in the 50s very much for the body of Christ
brother and I'm still out there trying to help the
body of Christ realize that we've got to work
together and we can't work together if there's
going to be people in Washington talking out of
both sides of their mouths to us and that's what
they're doing to us and uh I I didn't believe it
at first until I started compiling the information
myself I have letters from conference presidents
I have letters from people all over the world
letters from the white estate letters you wouldn't
believe boxes full of them confidential letters
that aren't supposed to be circulated which were
sent to me unsolicited all of which I consider to
be filled with duplicity evasion deliberate
and willful attempts not to tell the public
exactly what Mrs White's role is but to read
statements such as your reading here it scares me
because I'm concerned for my fellow Christians if
I weren't concerned I certainly wouldn't be flying
halfway across the United States and sitting here
under these Hot Lights despite John's Magnetic
Personality I'm concerned John I'm concerned also
but I repeat I think you are misreading the church
the total perspective is quite different from
what you have suggested I hope so and I hope
so for the body of Christ as Walter was saying
and I hope so for your sake because actually
after this night we are not Adventists you are
writing and as I have interviewed other people
that have said the same thing to me that you
are saying and watch them disappear my heart
went out to them when we did this program the
last time there were teachers right from the
college over here that were being investigated
on the very things that we were talking about in
1844 investigative judgment just preaching the
gospel and before we aired the program those
fellows knew that they would not have teaching
positions at the school and I'm saying that it's
not because we haven't felt this from people and
that we haven't asked it's that we're concerned
and Walter maybe you could I need to I need we I
think we need to ask the question here or give a
statement from our side of the tracks of what we
would need for reassurance that this what bill is
saying and what he is his life is on the line for
how we can have reassurance for the denomination
so that when he goes back John my life is not on
the line now you mentioned the teachers who uh
who did not believe in the 1844 investigative
judgment they were out of harmony with one of
the statements of Faith at the church and they
should not be teaching and being paid by church
members until the church changes its statement of
faith a man who cannot support those statements
really has no job if I was also out of Harmony
if I rejected that my conscience would say Bill
go out and do something else there's plenty of
other things I could do but you're so I think
your statement said that those people that that
disagreed with Ellen G white that was not a matter
for this Fellowship I came back to 1844 and the
investigative judgment it was her confirmation
of the vision according to at least 10 or 15
statements from your own Publications it was
her confirmation of it that gave it the authority
that carried it in the church without her word
behind it it would have been nothing the thought
that you said before that that was not a matter
for uh Fellowship within within the church
or breaking a fellowship the Judgment this
is one of the 27 fundamentals of faith it is
a point you see so if you disagree with that
you can be gone from the Adventist Church if you
felt that you were not merely having questions
about it and searching but if you thought that
you had to repudiate it that the scripture did
not support the 1844 investigative judgment then
you could not be an Adventist well you could not
no longer be a worker in the church at least
supported by a denominational employee someone
mentioned this Fellowship earlier in our programs
John but actually very very few people have been
this Fellowship some people have been fired
for various reasons and I dispute the number
here and there's a whole Spectrum here I don't
think it's it's just questions on Doctrine down
the line I think that is not right at all and
I dispute that categorically but it comes down
to the fundamentals of faith can I support that
in conscience uh can I even keep silence or do I
feel I have to stand up from the pulpit or in the
classroom and say the church is wrong on this you
know well until the church is ready to change then
that person really cannot be employed right we're
off time this week we've got some more questions
just the 30 second comment we're out Walter
I can't do it in 30 seconds I'm I'm really
concerned with the fact that we keep hearing
in the official Publications that you're not
going to be this fellowship or not put out of
the church if you disagree with Mrs White yet
all of the people that have major disagreements
have disagreed with Mrs White made that their
point and they were removed for that reason
gentlemen I really appreciate this conversation
and Bill thank you for coming tonight and uh I
think that on behalf of many of the evangelicals
that are listening in tonight we want to say
thank you for being here to express your views to
stand up for the views of the denomination at the
same time I hope that you will take back with
you our love and our concern and the fact that
we would like to continue to have fellowship and
Dialogue on matters of scripture and uh Dr Martin
uh I don't know what you're going to write in the
days ahead but thank you for coming tonight and
again being on the hot seat to give us your views
on this matter and thank you for being with us